I'm Tim Ferris,
best selling author and Human Guinea pig.
I'll show you how to make the impossible possible by bending the rules.
I'll find the world's best teachers and push myself to the edge to deconstruct,
decode,
and demystify some of the world's toughest challenges in record time
if I can do it.
So can you,
one of the best ways to learn something fast as to set steaks.
I don't want you to give it up for Mister Tim Ferriss over there now.
So here it goes there you can feel the power rising up in your loins five days.
This is like the first time I looked at Chinese characters.
Zero experience,
you're in,
you're in trouble,
okay.
And the world's best teachers
is four or five days were really enough time.
I have my doubts.
Sometimes accelerated learning requires serious acceleration.
The course is designed to kill you.
So here it goes.
I'm 50% excited and 50% totally scared shitless.
Five days you got a favorite chair,
accelerator,
zero experience.
But I'm terrified of it.
I do not.
Claim would be a good driver and the world's best teachers.
Stop.
Mistake.
And you and your car are toast.
Yeah.
Stand by camera free.
I've never been to the Philippines.
I only speak one word of gallery in that is.
Thank you.
So laba.
So you're telling me you speak like a Filipino now with language learning
experts on my side,
I will find out just how much took all,
like I can cram in four days and this is the day of reckoning for Tim.
Are you ready
this week?
I'm throwing down.